READ MORNING I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME YOU TO THE APRIL. SIX
TWENTY TWENTY TWO ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
. I WE HAVE FIFTY NINE BILLS TO
CONSIDER THIS MORNING AS A PART
OF OUR REGULAR ORDER HEARING.
BEFORE WE BEGAN I HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING NOTES TO COVER
RESULT LIKE O THANK
pIN FOR VACANCY ON THE COMMITTEE
TODAY AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH
FOR FILLING IN. FOR MR BIGELOW
THIS MORNING. WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING BY
VISITING THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AT A PRO DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV. PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY
WRITTEN TESTIMONY SUBMITTED TO
THE COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERED
PUBLIC COMMENT AND MAY BE READ
INTO THE RECORD OR REPRINTED.
ALL ARE ENCOURAGED TO WATCH. THE
HEARING FROM ITS LIVE STREAM ON
THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AT W. W. W.
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV
BACKSLASH TODAY'S. EVENTS THE
HEARING ROOM WILL BE OPEN FOR
ATTENDANCE OF THIS HEARING THE
PUBLIC MAY ALSO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS HEARING BY PHONE BY CALLING. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. WITH A
CONFIRMATION CODE OF. ONE EIGHT
FIVE ZERO ONE ONE ZERO ZERO THAT
NUMBER IS ALSO LISTED ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WE ENCOURAGE
THE PUBLIC TO MONITOR THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR UPDATES.
WE WILL ACCEPT PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ANY BILL PLACED ON THE SUSPENSE
FILE BY THE COMMITTEE TODAY AND
WHICH THE AUTHOR WAY
PRESENTATION BEFORE THE CLOSE OF
THE REGULAR ORDER HEARING.
TESTIMONY ON THESE BILLS WILL BE
LIMITED TO A STATEMENT OF NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND POSITION
ON THE BILL THE COMMITTEE WILL
ALLOW NO MORE THAN FORTY MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY ON ANY GIVEN BILL.
PREFERENCE WILL BE GIVEN TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. WE SEEK TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF ALL WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS SO WE CAN HAVE EFFECTIVE
DELIBERATION. AND DECISIONS ON
THE CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA. DUE TO COVER IT A
PAT ON PANDEMIC. I WE HAVE
LIMITED SPACE FOR THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE SO WE CAN ENSURE
EVERYONE MAINTAINS SIX FEET OF
SOCIAL DISTANCE. AS WE PROCEED
WITH THE WITNESSES AND PUBLIC
COMMENT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THE
ASSEMBLY HAS RULES TO ENSURE WE
MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN EFFICIENT
AND FAIR HEARING. WE APPLY THESE
RULES TO ALL PEOPLE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR PROCEEDINGS.
IN ADDITION THIS YEAR WE WILL
AGAIN COMPLY WITH ALL PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDERS ARISING OUT OF THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IN ORDER
TO FACILITATE THE GOAL OF
HEARING AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC
WITHIN THE LIMITS OF OUR TIME WE
WILL NOT PERMIT CONDUCT THAT
ISRUPTS. DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. WILL
NOT ACCEPT DISRUPTIVE BEHAVIOR
OR BEHAVIOR THAT INCITES OR
THREATENS VIOLENCE EVEN VEILED
THREATS. IF YOU CAME INTO THE
HEARING ROOM TODAY THE SERGEANTS
DIRECTED YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
RULES FOR PUBLIC ATTENDANCE AND
PARTICIPATION WHICH WERE POSTED
OUTSIDE THE DOOR. I ENCOURAGE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WERE
IN ATTENDANCE TO BE AWARE OF AND
OBSERVE THOSE RULES. PLEASE BE
AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS OF THESE
RULES MAY BE SUBJECT MAY SUBJECT
YOU TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. COMMENTERS
TO IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS MEETING WELL. MEETING BY
MAKING THREATS INCLUDING BILL
THREATS OF POTENTIAL VIOLENCE
WILL BE RULED OUT OF ORDER AND
TREATED AS A DISRUPTION. I WILL
LOOK TO THE SECRETARY TO SEE IF
WE HAVE A QUORUM. REPORTER YEAH
. THEY WERE WAITING FOR ONE MORE
ONE MORE MEMBER TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE OUR QUORUM AND THERE WE
WILL LOOK TO TAKE OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS BUT IF I COULD
LET'S MOVE TO- THE ITEMS THAT
ARE BEFORE US TODAY. THAT ARE
DUE PASS- AND WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE SO WE'LL JUST BE
ABLE TO HEAR YOUR PRESENTATION
AND- WE'LL TAKE ACTION. ONCE WE
HAVE A QUORUM- LET'S SEE I SEE
MISTER GRAYSON IS HERE AND SO-
MR GRAYSON YOU'RE HERE 2% ON AB. TWO ZERO FIVE SIX. MEGAN BEGAN
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY FIFTY SIX WHICH SIMPLY
EXT EXPANDS THE BOARD OF PILOT
COMMISSIONERS AUTHORITY TO
ADJUST AND CREATE SURCHARGES AND
INCLUDE COST. OF REPAIRING
EXISTING PILOT BOATS OR THE
ACQUISITION OF NEW PILOT BOATS
TO MEET EMISSIONS REQUIREMENTS
IMPOSED BY THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. RECENTLY CARD
HAS OF THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS
THAT WOULD APPLY MORE STRINGENT
REQUIREMENTS TO IN USE AND NEW
VESSELS THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
CREATE DIFFICULT AND FINANCIAL
BURDENS FOR THE STATE. MANDATED
PILOTAGE INFRASTRUCTURE.
COMPOUNDED WITH VARIOUS
CHALLENGES THAT THE CODE-
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT ON
TO THE SHIPPING TRADE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SUPPLY CHAIN
AB TWENTY FIFTY SIX WOULD SIMPLY
AUTHORIZE THE BOARD TO ADJUST
THE PILOT BOAT SURCHARGE. TO
INCLUDE THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH
THE ACQUISITION OF NEW PILOT
BOATS OR REPOWERING EXISTING
BOATS IN ORDER TO MEET CARBON
EMISSIONS REQUIREMENTS BY
AUTHORIZING THE SURCHARGES THIS
WILL ENSURE THAT PILOT VESSELS
ARE ABLE TO MEET THE PROPOSED
CARBOXYLATION. WHILST
CONTRIBUTING TO THE STATE'S
OVERALL EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS
THIS BILL HAS NO FISCAL COST AS
COMMITTEE NOTED IN THEIR
ANALYSIS THIS BILL WILL ONLY
EXPAND ELIGIBLE YOU. REVENUE
GENERATED BY A- CERTAIN JUST
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CLOSE CONSIDERATION OF THIS
MEASURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
KNIVES AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
I DO YOU HAVE ANY ELSE'S THAT
ARE GOING TO BE PERCENT UNDER
GOD- IS THERE ANYONE WHO IS HERE
IN THE- CHAMBERS IT HAS POSITION
OF SUPPORT. THE NINE WILL TURN
TO THE PHONE OPERATOR. THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES THAT
ARE LINED UP TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FELL BY ZERO TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT. AND MISTER KERR
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP. ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM TODAY THAT'S
HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THE NON OWNER OPERATOR
ANYONE ONLINE TO LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO. TWENTY FIFTY
SIX. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY
FIFTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. OKAY
WELL WAS WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE WILL TURN. MADAM
SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL THE
STOCK WAS A CORE. HOLDEN THERE
SMITH BRIAN CALDERON. CORREA
DOLLY. DAVIES MIKE FONG YOUR
VINCE FONG- GABRIEL. EDUARDO
GARCIA LEVINE. QUOQUE.
ROBERT RIVAS WEBER- WITH. A
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED- ANY
MEMBERS HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THIS BILL.
BEEN MOVED IT'S BEEN SECONDED DR
BURKE. THEY'RE GONNA MAKE
MISTAKES. OF THIS BILL IS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL I'M SORRY-
DISABILITIES AL WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING WITH MISS DAVIS
VOTING HI AND MISS DOLLY VOTING
NO. REGULATIONS THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW TAKE A PAUSE ON THE- DO
PASSED BILLS FOR SECOND AND SEE
IF WE CAN ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR
. ARE BILLS THAT ARE ON CONSENT
OF- MOOD BY DOCTOR QUIRK AGAIN
BY THE VICE CHAIR. AND THIS-
THIS BILL IS- OUT. OKAY. INSTEAD
LET'S LET'S CALL THE ROLL. HI
MEASURES ARE ON CONSENT AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY TWO
COMMITTEE ON BANKING AND FINANCE
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY ONE
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY SIX AGILA
CURRY AB NINETEEN OH SEVEN
BALLOT QUE HAN. AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY TWO BOERNER HORVATH AB
NINETEEN FORTY SIX
BOERNER HORVATH AB NINETEEN
TWENTY SIX TROY AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY THREE CUNNINGHAM AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY FIVE DAVIS AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY THREE GRAYSON
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR- IN
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO
PATTERSON AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY TWO
PATTERSON AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SIX QUIRK-SILVA. AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX I OUT THOUGH AB
TWENTY TO SEVENTY SEATTLE.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN I SMITH. BRIAN
CALDERON. SPECIFIC IT'S A FELONY
SMITH I BRIAN CALDERON CALDERON
I CARILLO MEGAN DOLLY MEGAN
DOLLY I DAVIS DAVIS I MIGHT FONG
MIKE FONG I VINCE FONG BY VINCE
FONG I GABRIEL GABRIEL I EDUARDO
GARCIA. LEVINE LEVINE I KOK.
HOOK I ROBERT RIVAS WEBER WEBER
I- IRWIN- WHEN I. OFTEN. CONSENT
CALENDARS ADOPTED TWELVE ZERO
I'D LIKE TO KNOW DISPENSED WITH
THE SUSPENSE CALENDAR AND MADAM
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE READ
THE SUSPENSE. AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTEEN AGILA CURRY AB NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE OCULAR CURRY AB
NINETEEN HUNDRED ARAMBULA AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
BOERNER HORVATH AB SEVENTEEN OH
SIX ME A BONTA AB EIGHTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN MIA BONTA A. B.
EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN BRIAN. AB
TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN CALDERON
EIGHT TWENTY TWO SIXTY TWO
CALDERON AB SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN
COOPER AB IN SEVENTEEN TWENTY
TWO COOPER AB TWENTY EIGHTY
EIGHT COOPER AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
DAVIES AB TWENTY FOUR OH NINE
DAVIES AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR
CRISTINA GARCIA AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE. EDUARDO GARCIA AB
NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR GIPSON. AB
TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR GIPSON AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY NINE GIPSON AB
TWENTY TWO SIXY EIGHT GRAY AB
SIXTEEN OH FOUR HOLDEN AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY SIX JONES SAWYER AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR LEE AB
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED LOW. AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY THREE MAIENSCHEIN AB
TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT- DONALD AB
TWENTY SEVENTY ONE PATTERSON AB
SIXTEEN FORTY NINE QUIRK-SILVA
AB TWENTY FIFTY TWO QUIRK-SILVA
AB SEVENTEEN OH THREE RAMOS AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY FOUR RAMOS.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY REYES AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN BLANCA
RUBIO AB EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX
VALLADARES AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
SEVEN VALLADARES AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO WARD AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY EIGHT WEBER AB NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE WICKS AB TWENTY EIGHT
FOURTEEN WOULD. SPENCE CALENDAR
IS THE AND APPROVED WILL NOW
MOVE BACK TO OUR PRESENTATIONS
AND WITNESSES ON TO PASS BILLS
MR PATTERSON YOU'RE HERE. AND WE
WILL RECOGNIZE YOU KNOW. THIS
YEAR PRESENTED ON AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. HE BURDEN BUT EVERY
SECOND BY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
UP MEMBERS. I APPRECIATE THAT.
OF THE QUICKER. SUPPORT ALSO BE
I'LL BE QUICK- THIS BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT ANY CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
YOU RECEIVE STATE FUNDING FROM
REDUCING SCHOLARSHIP FINANCIAL
AID TO STUDENTS WHO ARE CURRENT
OR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH THERE ARE
ALREADY NUMEROUS CHALLENGES
THAT- THESE YOUNG PEOPLE FACE
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
PURSUING A COLLEGE DEGREE. MANY
OF THE STUDENTS LACK FAMILY
SUPPORT FINANCIAL RESOURCES
GUIDANCE THAT MANY OF THEIR
PEERS HAVE AND THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO MAXIMIZE THEIR POTENTIAL
THROUGH SCHOLARSHIPS AND
FINANCIAL AID. RISING COSTS OF
HOUSING BOOKS TRANSPORTATION
IT'S AFTER. RELATING TO HIGHER
EDUCATION- SOMETIMES CAN BE
IMPEDIMENTS SAID A TO THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE. HERE TO TESTIFY-
IN SUPPORTERS REBECA GONZALEZ
WITH NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS SHE IS CALLING IN
FOR A QUICK SUPPORT COMMENT.
RETURN TO YOUR WITNESS OF
REBEKAH GONZALEZ. IS ON THE
PHONE LINE- YES I AM HOPEFULLY
YOU CAN HEAR ME AB HELLO THIS IS
WORK HELLO THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ AND I REPRESENT THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE
REPRESENT SOCIAL WORKERS WITH A
DEGREE IN SOCIAL WORK AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER. AGED OUT AND ARE NOW
MOVING INTO THEIR ADULT LIVES
IT'S A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES AND
MAY HAVE LIVED THERE MULTIPLE
TRAUMAS AND DISRUPTIVE ADVANCED
BY THE TIME THEY ENTER THEIR
COLLEGE YEARS. SOME OF THESE
CHALLENGES ARE ACCUSED AND OR
MAKE LACK MULTIPLE FOSTER HOMES
PLACEMENTS LACK OF CONTINUITY
EDUCATION AND AN ARRAY OF LOSSES
INCLUDING RELATIONSHIPS WITH.
FAMILY FRIENDS AND SIBLINGS. I
THINK SPIRITS IS CAN ALSO CROSS
WITH A IN MAY L. MAY THAT. IS
PROBLEMS AND A LACK OF. CURRENT
AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. OFTEN
DO NOT HAVE FAMILY SUPPORTER
GUIDANCE AS THEY ENTERED COLLEGE
THE THEY'RE ALL HUGE HURDLES TO
DATE AND ADDING ON THE FINANCIAL
PRESS PRESSURED AND TRYING TO
HELP FOR COLLEGE CAN ONLY MAKE
MATTERS WORSE. MANY SOCIAL
WORKERS WORK WITH FOSTER YOUTH
AND WITHHOLDING IT WE GUIDE THEM
AT THE EXIT CARE BY HELPING TO
SET THEM UP FOR SUCCESS. WHETHER
THAT BE BY PURSUING A COLLEGE
DEGREE OR BY DIRECTLY ENTERING
THE JOB MARKET. WE NEED TO
ENSURE WE GIVE OUR CURRENT AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH ALL THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO SUCCEED IN
LIFE. AND EDUCATION IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT TO LOOK THEY
NEED TO PROVIDE A BETTER LIFE
FOR THEMSELVES. AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY ONE WILL ELIMINATE THE
PRACTICE FOR THE SCHOLARSHIP
DISPLAEMENT FOR CURRENT AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. TO WORRY
ABOUT HOW THEY FOR THE BOOK
THERE WERE. THERE TO. ARE THERE
NOW MEAL. IS BILL WILL ALLOW
THESE. IN ARE. TO PER. ON
OBTAINING THEIR COLLEGE DEGREE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A FAMILY MEMBER
PATTERSON AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
ONE. THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO- SUPPORT THIS BILL AT
THIS TIME. THE NINE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES- IS THERE ANYONE
ONLINE TO. ADD THEIR SUPPORT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM THE FOR MIND. YES I
WOULD. Q. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR AB
SIXTY SEVENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME WHEN FILED BY ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY IS KILLING UP.
ANYONE IN THE- HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO ADD A COMMENT OF
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SAYING
NINE. WOULD LIKE TO HEAR- PHONE
OPERATOR IF THERE ANY IS ANYONE
ON THE LINE I WOULD LIKE TO
VOICE THEIR OPPOSITION. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO. EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FOLLOWED BY ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR THERE'S NO PUBLIC COMMENT
EXPRESSING OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS OR-
THOUGHTS TO SHARE CA. DR COURT.
RIGHT BILL CAN'T WAIT TO VOTE
FOR IT ON THE FLOOR Q. HE THAT.
BUT THE GOLD SEAL ENDORSEMENT.
BETTER WHAT'S I THINK WE HAVE
THIS IS A RICK ROLL CALL OF
BIRDS OUT ON A ROLL CALL A
DEFENSE OF CONGRATULATIONS ON
THAT VERY MUCH. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF THESE WHO ARE GOING TO BE
BENEFITED BY THIS AS IT MOVES
ALONG TO GET TO THE FLOOR- I
ALSO WANNA JUST CONFIRM THAT I'M
WAITING PRESENTATION AB. TWO
ZERO SEVEN ONE SPENCE. JUST
CONFIRM THAT OKAY THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU. MR LEVINE ARE
YOU HAVE AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
FIVE. AND AS YOU'RE MAKING YOUR
WAY TO PRESENT WERE WAITING OR
LAST PRESENTER MISTER COOPER ON
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING. RIGHT HI ALL DONE.
WE'RE GOOD YEAH ALL RIGHT
FANTASTIC THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE WOULD
REQUIRE THAT LOCAL PUBLIC ACCESS
CHANNELS BE DELIVERED TO THE
PUBLIC IN HIGH DEFINITION OR THE
MOST ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY USED BY
LOCAL BROADCAST TELEVISION
CHANNELS IMPORTANTLY THIS WOULD
ENSURE THAT ANY DOCUMENTS
PRESENTED AT GOVERNMENT MEETINGS
ARE READABLE AND WOULD MAKE
CAPTIONS AVAILABLE FOR THOSE WHO
ARE HEARING IMPAIRED. OR DEAF AS
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS THE BILL
HAS NEGLIGIBLE STATE COSTS IF
ANY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DO YOU DO
NOT HAVE ANY WITNESSES TO EITHER
SOME PEOPLE CONTENT OKAY. SO
WE'LL GO TO THE MAIN WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE- AN OPERATOR CAN
YOU- LET IN THE WITNESSES THAT.
WERE HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS BILL. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX PLEASE TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY IN PRESS STAR
ONE AT THIS SIZE STAR FOLLOWED
BY THE ONE STAR FONG I'M SO
SORRY ONE FALL BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE FILED BY ZERO TODAY. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI EIGHTEEN ENOUGH
SO I DON'T KNOW IT'S AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY FIVE. AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY FIVE IS THE BILL WE'RE
HEARING. THEY WERE LOOKING FOR
WITNESSES. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
YOU SAY YOU HAVE A WITNESS ON I
WAS INFORMED THAT THERE ARE SOME
WITNESSES THAT MAY BE CALLING
ANTI OKAY JUST TAKE THOSE WERE
JUST OF THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
MAY BE CALLING IN IS LIKE ME TO
USE GOTCHA ALL RIGHT AND WILL
LOOK TO THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT. ON IT AB. TWENTY SIX
THIRTY FIVE. EXTRA SUPPORT FOR
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AT
THIS TIME- MISTER CHAIR WE DO A
ONE PARTICIPANT CUED UP WE'LL GO
TO LINE ELEVEN. HELLO THIS IS
CHRIS MILLER FROM PASADENA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR COMMUNITY MEDIA
WEST REGION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. AND THE FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT. SOMEONE REALLY
SMART MOST ANY OTHER PERSON FROM
PASADENA. IT'S MORE PEOPLE COME
FROM PRESIDENT ORGANS. AND
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME OKAY WE APPRECIATE THAT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM- TO VOICE OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL SAYING NINE PHONE OPERATOR
ANYONE ON THE LINE WOULD LIKE TO
OTHER COMMENTS OF OPPOSITION.
PRESS OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME WHEN FILED BY ZERO. ONE
MOMENT WE TO AVOID KILLING OUT.
WILL BE WITH US MOMENTARILY
MISTER CHAIR. VIADUCT OR
COWORKERS OR SECOND. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE SEVENTEEN YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CAROLINE BEALE HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF DIRECT TV WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND WE HAVE
COMMUNICATED OUR CONCERNS WITH
THE OFFICE OFFICE AND HOPE THAT
WE CAN WORK THROUGH OUR
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THAT THERE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. IT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR. THIS BILL IS OUT ON THE
B. ROLL CALL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PETTY. WITH THIS REVENUE TO
SECOND. I THOUGHT I THOUGHT I
SAW GARCIA REASONS. MR GARCIA A
SECOND. NOT ON THE ROLL CALL.
CHIU COOPER WELCOME EVERYONE AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX THIS IS YOUR
MEMBERS. THE MOVE THE DR CORPUS
THEIR SECOND. THANK AMADOR TO
WEBER. YOUR MEMBERS AB EIGHTY
SIX COSTA MINOR AN OBSERVABLE TO
DIR THERE'S NO COST TO CALTRANS
HERE THEY TESTIFIED SUPPORTERS
TEMPERAMENTS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NEVADA INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS THE SPONSORS
OF AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS AND SHARE AS
NOTED BY THE AUTHOR MINOR VERBAL
CUSTODY I AREN'T SPONSORED BY.
THEIR NOTION OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES THAT YOU HAVE ON PHONE
LINES YOU KNOW OF THIS GROUP- NO
OKAY. I WILL WILL ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
NAY NONE OWNER OPERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ONLINE I WOULD LIKE TO
VOICE THEIR SUPPORT FOR A BI
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR A BI EIGHTEEN EIGHT EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
AND PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
VOICE THEIR OPPOSITION TO. A. B.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX. THE NON
OWNER OPERATOR ANYONE ONLINE IT
HAS THE VOICE OF UPPER
OPPOSITION. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX.
PRESS OPPOSITION FOR AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FILED BY ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY.-COMMENTS QUESTIONS THE AUTHOR.
OF THE SAYS THE MOTION SECOND
DISS OUT ON A ROLL CALL- WITH MR
FONG VOTING NO AND MISTER SMITH
NOT VOTING. THANK YOU THANK YOU
. THE DISPENSES WITH THE OF
PRESENTATIONS FOR US TODAY WILL
NOW TURN TO. ANY ADD ONS FOR
CONSENT. IN MADAM SECRETARY. I
DON'T FALL CONSENT CALENDAR
CALDERON. I. CORREA. EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I
ROBERT RIVAS.
PUBLICADA WHAT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR CONSENT WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO AND OTHER ITEMS
RIGHT NOW WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE UP THE OF PUBLIC COMMENT
I'D LIKE TO NOW OPEN UP THE
HEARING THE COMMENTS BY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ON ANY BILL NOT
PRESENT IN A COMMITTED TODAY-
PLEASE BE SURE TO LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. IF THERE'S
ANYONE IS IN ROOM HE WOULD LIKE
TO STATE THEIR POSITION ON THE
BILL PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. SEE NON OPERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE TELEPHONE
LINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO STATE
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL. THAT
WAS PROVED NOT PRESENTED TODAY.
IN CENTER SUSPENSE. AT THIS TIME
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO OUR
EXPRESSED. OR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ZERO
ON ANY OF THESE BILLS. NOW ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE DO HAVE ONE
KILLING OUT. IT SHOULD BE WITH
US MOMENTARILY MISTER CHAIR
THERE WITH AN OPERATOR OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. AND
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE SIXTEEN
YOUR OPEN SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU I'M ANY OTHER
APPLE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. OKAY
WELL THEN THAT WILL CONCLUDE OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL. NOW LOOK TO
RESUME ADD ONS TO THE BILLS THAT
ARE BEEN DISPENSED WITH-
ADDITIONAL.
OKAY THEN THE ONLY MEMBERS WHO
WE WOULD BE WAITING ON OUR
MEMBERS WHO ARE CHAIRING
COMMITTEES AND SO. A CLEAR IT'S
WHAT TIME THEY COULD GET HERE SO
WE WILL. CONSIDER THIS MEETING
ADJOURNED.